KOBI MAGNEZI: Hello, and thank
you for joining us today.
My name is Kobi Magnezi.
I'm product manager for GKE.
And today I would like to
share with you some of the best
practices on how to leverage
GKE to power a competitive IT
e-commerce infrastructure.
First, let's start
with looking at some
of the drivers for
e-commerce organization
and the requirements
they imply for
the supporting infrastructure.
In a recent validation study
of Google Cloud solution
for e-commerce, the ESG analysis
found that retail industry
is focused on providing
better and more differentiated
customer experience
through specifically
digital transformation
initiatives with about 50%
of retail organization
strategically prioritizing
this objective.
For retailers, creating
an e-commerce presence
increases not just the
touchpoints with the customer,
but also the sales
opportunity, especially when
events like the pandemic
pushes more customers
to online channels.
At the same time,
it also increases
the competitive landscape.
To maintain the competitiveness,
an e-commerce infrastructure
must provide, one, high
performance; two, scalability;
three, reliability
and availability;
four, customization
and innovation;
and finally, flexibility.
Let's look deeper
into these areas
to understand how Kubernetes
and GKE address these areas.
We will also provide
some recommendation
for configuration and
options that you would want
to consider for your cluster.
Many customers use GCP to
migrate, modernize, and improve
their deployments.
GCP infrastructure and
networking are powering GKE.
So when you create a
Kubernetes cluster on GKE,
we provision the machine and
the resources needed for GKE
to properly run your cluster's
control plane and nodes on GCP.
The Kubernetes
cluster control plane
is fully managed by
us, backed by an SLA.
We will keep the control
plane up to date,
and we'll scale it
automatically up and down
when cluster size changes.
For efficiency and
high performance,
you can choose what
type of machine,
what machine configuration
best meets your needs
for your different node pools.
And as demands
change over time, so
does the load on your
e-commerce workloads.
Scaling is necessary
to ensure that GKE
grows to match your need.
Think about the number of
pods, the number of nodes.
GKE includes several
autoscaling capabilities
that will automatically
resize your cluster based
on your configuration and
signals that we monitor.
HPA, for example, automatically
increases or decreases
the number of pods on your
cluster based on utilization.
With VPA and NPA, you
can enable vertical scale
for both your nodes and pods.
And if capacity planning
is part of your practice,
especially for peak season
like Black Friday, Cyber Monday
or New Year, you may want
to reserve GCE capacity.
With GCE reservation,
when your cluster
requires to scale,
repair, or upgrade,
it will have a reserved
pool of dedicated resources
available for the performance.
You can also create a specific
or non-specific reservation,
and GKE will create new
resources based on the pool
that you reserved.
Now let's talk
about availability.
And it's important
to distinguish
between application
availability and infrastructure
availability.
The availability of the
business application,
which the customers
interact with,
and the availability of the
infrastructure, which hosts
and support the application.
On the application
side, the impact
of insufficient availability can
be an unresponsive e-commerce
website or unreachable service.
On the infrastructure
side, the impact
can happen at different levels.
At the cluster
level, for example,
when nodes become
unresponsive or when pods get
rescheduled, at zone level,
or at a regional level,
where there is a connectivity
issue, for example.
While both the application
and the infrastructure
impacts the overall
availability,
it is actually the
business application
that drives the decision
around redundancy, deployments,
and architecture.
With this definition
in mind, it is
important to understand how
GKE is structured as a shared
responsibility product.
The data plane, the nodes where
the e-commerce workloads are
deployed, are the most
critical piece for customers,
as any reliability issue can
directly impact the business.
The Kubernetes control plane is
the next most critical piece,
as it's responsible
for scaling, repairing,
and managing the deployments.
And then most of the workloads
deployed on the data plane
can probably survive an outage,
a short outage of the control
plane without too much impact.
The GKE control plane
on the leftmost side
is the least critical
piece, as they are mainly
focused on the operations
and the management of the GKE
control plane.
Let's look on the two
most important pieces
from a reliability perspective.
Both control planes
and nodes can
be provisioned in a single
zone, a zonal cluster,
as illustrated on
the right side,
or can be provisioned
in three different zones
within a region, a
regional cluster.
There are some cases where
zonal cluster topology better
serves your needs
and constraints.
We do recommend, however,
to use regional cluster
for highly available Kubernetes
infrastructure, especially
for production workloads.
For control planes,
the redundancy
provide high
availability, and in
turn provide higher SLA
for the Kubernetes API.
But besides of the
API availability,
the API availability
in the control pane
doesn't really impact
the workloads themselves
necessarily.
The control plane is also
responsible for maintaining
the cluster with
scaling, repairing,
and other vital operations.
And you may want to take
into consideration, based
on the nature of your
e-commerce workloads and needs,
the type of topology that is
right for your architecture.
Since we provision
compute resources
on GCP for the
Kubernetes clusters,
node availability are based on
the Compute Engine availability
for instances provisioned in
a single or multiple zone.
Finally, the availability
of your application
is closely tied to
the node availability,
as you can imagine.
And luckily, Kubernetes
offers an easy way
to create multiple instances
of your application
for higher availability.
One great way to secure
higher availability
for your application, and also
to reduce potential disruption,
is the use of PDB, or
Pod Disruption Budget.
PDB allows you to state
your disruption tolerance.
In other words, if your
application is replicated,
you can specify
the minimum number
of replicas that can be
disrupted when maintenance even
happens.
In the example that I have on
this slide here on the right
side, we specify that we cannot
tolerate less than two replicas
of our application.
This is just another way of
saying max unavailable equal
one, in case we have three
replicas of the application.
GKE respects PDB
up to 60 minutes,
and a termination grace
policy up to 60 minutes.
When a security patch or
Kubernetes update is rolled out
on your cluster, GKE
will perform the upgrade
in a way that satisfies
the PDB configuration.
The other thing
that you want GKE
to know about your workloads
is what consideration
it needs to apply
when it schedules
your pods on different
nodes in the cluster.
By default, the GKE and
the Kubernetes scheduler
automatically spread your
pods across the nodes,
whether it's regional
or zonal cluster.
However some e-commerce
applications, and specifically
stateful workloads,
like Redis, for example,
require a quorum of servers
to successfully work
in a redundant deployment.
Without specific
instruction, Kubernetes
may decide to
co-locate all the pods
for your stateful
application, stateful set
on the same machine,
on the same node,
and basically create a single
point of failure and risk
to the availability of the
e-commerce application.
Exactly for those reasons,
we can use pod anti/affinity
to ensure pods are not scheduled
on the same specific node
if we set the criteria.
So if I require a
quorum of servers
to properly operate a stateful
application, for example,
I would want
Kubernetes to refrain
from scheduling all the
replicas on the same machine.
So if something happened
to that machine,
it won't take down all
the different replicas
of my application.
On the flip side, there
are some applications,
workloads that may actually
benefit from being co-located
on the same machine.
For example, if you
have a web server
and you want to co-locate
it with the cache
service for better
performance and lower latency.
In this case, you might
want to use pod affinity.
Another important aspect of
the infrastructure reliability
is monitoring and specifically
providing accurate signals
to Kubernetes about your
workload state and health.
The first signal in this
slide is readiness probe,
which basically defines a
signal for when a workload is
ready to serve traffic.
Say for example, if a workload
takes some time to start,
the lack of such signal may
lead to Kubernetes starting
to send traffic to a
not yet ready to respond
workload, which will lead
to time out and impact
its experience.
The second signal here
is liveness probe,
which provides a health
signal that Kubernetes
uses to determine whether
it should initiate a repair
and replace of a
faulty instance or not.
Defining an upgrade
strategy for your cluster
is another important
dimension of reliability.
A new Kubernetes minor version
is released roughly every four
months from open source.
And patch versions are
released more frequently.
Because Kubernetes clusters
contain both control plane
and nodes, there are
two places to manage
when it comes to
keeping your clusters up
to date with releases, security
patches, and bug fixes.
Luckily, GKE offers
different ways
to keep your cluster's
infrastructure up to date.
Being a shared
responsibility product,
GKE keeps control plane
automatically updated.
And alternatively, you can
keep your node version upgraded
automatically, or initiate
the upgrade manually
by running your own
script, or using our API.
To ensure that your
infrastructure is up to date
and also being kept as such in
a safe and non-destructive way,
we highly recommend the use
of multiple environments.
So when there is a new
version or a patch,
it can be rolled out for
testing and qualification
on staging and
testing environments
before it hits the
production environment.
In general, we recommend
to use the same version
in all environments so you get
consistency and correctness
of your qualification process.
However, you may want to
consider a second development
environment where newer
releases can be tested.
This can be useful when a new
GKE feature or Kubernetes API
are being introduced,
and you want
to test them to get a head start
and be ready for the market
when you have a
new feature that's
relying on this capability.
The process of upgrading
your Kubernetes clusters,
keeping the control plane
and nodes preferably
in sync when it comes
to the same version,
and also in a supported version,
and also in a supported version
SKU that is mandated
by open source,
that process can be thorny
and very cumbersome.
And one way to simplify it
is by using release channel.
Release channel
in GKE allows you
to choose your upgrade path.
It also controls
the type of upgrade
that will be applied
on your cluster.
Some customers may want to use
the latest Kubernetes version,
because, as I mentioned
before, dependencies
on a new API or
capability, or maybe they
have a specific
business objective.
In this case, you may want to
use the rapid channel, which
is closer to open source
in terms of releases.
Other customers may prefer
stability over functionality.
And in that case,
they will choose
either the stable channel
or the regular channel,
which are the ones we recommend
for production workloads.
When it comes to patching
or upgrading your cluster,
the nodes where the e-commerce
application are deployed,
we replace them.
Those nodes are being replaced
with new provisioned machine
running the newer
Kubernetes GKE version when
an upgrade takes place.
When nodes are replaced,
as you can imagine,
pods running on
them are gracefully
shut down so the node can
be drained and replaced.
On the GKE side,
node upgrade used
to follow the
workflow of delete,
then create, meaning
that when we upgrade,
GKE used to drain a node,
delete it, and then replace it
with a new one.
However, to increase
the availability
and also to reduce
disruption, node upgrade
is now happening through
surge upgrade, where
we change actually the order.
We first create a new
node for the upgrade,
and only when that node
is ready and available,
we gracefully
drain the old node.
Not only that surge reduces
disruption to existing nodes,
it also allows you to control
the number of nodes that
can be upgraded concurrently.
The default setting
is one node at a time.
So keep that in mind.
If you are using large
clusters with many nodes,
you probably want to
change that number
so more nodes can be
concurrently upgraded
at the same time.
It is clear that sustaining
a competitive e-commerce
infrastructure requires a
continuous upgrade practice.
However as we all know,
sometimes business requirements
may change, especially when
disruption simply cannot be
tolerated.
For example, think
about peak seasons,
like Black Friday, Cyber Monday,
New Year, or major company
events, trade fairs,
or something like that.
We recommend you to
use an exclusion window
for this event.
With an exclusion
window, you can
specify a range of
dates in which you
want to refrain completely
from any type of maintenance.
You can also set up
maintenance windows
to specify when you prefer
maintenance to happen.
This can help you to improve
predictability of the upgrade,
and also allow to control
the time of the upgrades
on different clusters.
Exclusion windows and
maintenance windows
can greatly help you control
the disruption and reduce risk.
But we've seen with
many retail customers
that they are
actually experiencing
different requirements
during different times
of their fiscal year.
For example, an
e-commerce infrastructure
is most likely to follow
some regulation or compliance
like PCI, for example.
And this compliance
has specific guidelines
when it comes to keeping
your software up to date
and how frequent and
fast a new security
patch should be consumed.
In this case, I might want
to allow all type of upgrades
and patches on both
control planes and nodes
throughout a low season month,
while during a high peak
season, like Black
Friday, Cyber Monday,
I want to refrain completely
from any type of maintenance
so my workloads will
not be affected.
And then also in
some other cases,
I might be OK with just
patching my clusters, both nodes
and control planes,
but would want
to refrain from upgrading
to the next minor version.
We believe that this
level of flexibility
is actually needed for
e-commerce infrastructure
so they can control
maintenance events,
and also the risk
level associated
with the change in accordance
to their business needs.
This way you can delegate all
patching and upgrades to GKE,
while being able to instruct
it on what type of upgrades
you want to allow, the scope,
and when to initiate a process.
So now that we know how upgrades
and patches get rolled out,
I think it's important to
also stay informed and know
about changes coming
to your clusters.
One place to learn
about GKE releases
is, of course, the GKE
Release Notes page,
which includes links
to the release schedule
and the version support policy.
But we also recommend the use
of GKE Notification, which
includes notification
for upgrades
and upgrade available events.
GKE Notification, which
is based on Pub/Sub,
you can listen to upgrade
available events, which
when they fire,
indicate that there
is a newer version or patch
available for your cluster.
In turn, you can use that
event and trigger a workflow
to apply these
patches, for example,
on your testing cluster.
So the infrastructure version
can be vetted and qualified
before it gets released to
your production environment.
Finally, a robust
e-commerce infrastructure
must also provide
some flexibility
so you can apply some
changes on the fly
in a non-disruptive way.
We've identified
several common places
where changes
involve disruption,
because when you
apply these changes,
it actually requires us to
recreate the machine or node
pool.
For example, you may need to
change network tags in order
to change firewall rules,
or routes of your commerce
application.
You can now do so, you
can change network tags
for existing running VMs,
without recreating the VMs,
and basically applying
this change on the fly.
The same thing goes
for node things, which
you can use to steer away
pods from specific nodes,
or labels, which are
used to schedule pods
on particular nodes.
All these three options are now
modifiable without requiring
recreation of the machine.
So we've learned
from the ESG report
that there are specific areas an
e-commerce infrastructure must
cover to maintain
competitiveness.
High availability,
where redundancy
is important to avoid
single point of failure.
That applies to both
control plane and nodes.
Scalability, use multiple
replicas, the use of PDB
to avoid disruption,
affinity and anti/affinity
to better instruct
the Kubernetes
scheduler on how to optimize the
deployment of your workloads.
Reliability and
availability, remember
that control planes are
fully managed on GKE,
but can go through maintenance.
Make sure that you don't
create unnecessary dependencies
on the control plane
API in your application
to avoid disruption
to your application
when control plane
is being upgraded.
And then, finally,
for flexibility, there
are some changes that
can be applied on the fly
and do not impose any disruption
for existing workloads.
To close up, I want to share
a quote from Loblaw, a GKE
e-commerce customer, who
achieved great success using
both GCP and GKE, despite
going through the unexpected
challenges of the pandemic.
Loblaw migrated and
modernized its e-commerce
with GCP and GKE, and also
leveraged the Black Friday,
Cyber Monday white glove service
for additional peace of mind
during this critical
business period.
This resulted in better
performance at scale,
faster application
development and deployment,
high availability, and
elimination of Black Friday,
Cyber Monday outages.
And while keeping the
infrastructure up to date,
Loblaw managed to leverage
the different infrastructure
capabilities to roll out their
COVID-19 vaccines delivery
system in nine weeks
instead of 18 months.
There's much more to learn.
You can download
the full ESG report
from the first link on this
page and find more documentation
best practices on the GKE
website on the second link.
Thank you so much for
watching this session.
I hope you enjoy the
rest of your Google Next.